given the reception of this movie some
people might think that Fox is just run
by a bunch of but I
respectfully disagree
I think Fox is a supergenius company
because they set out to make a movie
that would make people want to watch the
old shity fantastic for movies again
success I walked out of this movie going
man I want to see that Fantastic Four
movie with Jessica Alba and Captain
America you know the one where they did
Doctor Doom better wrap your brain
around that
and testing before so fantastic for us
ironically the fourth attempt at making
a Fantastic Four movie and funny enough
the fourth success at making an
abomination in the name of the Fantastic
Four in this movie miles teller plays
Reed Richards and the government's
trying to crack interdimensional travel
and so for reasons that the file logic
this group gets brought together and
they go through the dimension they come
back with superpowers and here we are
now there were some things in this movie
where I saw where they were going with
it and I did like it at least I like the
concept the execution has some things to
be desired but I feel like I'm treading
on spoiler territory telling you what I
kind of liked about the movie but if you
truly do take my word to heart you do
listen to me it doesn't matter because
you're not gonna watch this movie
because I'm gonna tell you not to but I
did like the fact that the government's
ultimately funding this thing and they
come back with super power so the
government ultimately wants to weaponize
these kids that was kind of interesting
because I feel like that's what would
happen if this happened again not done
in the smoothest way ever but I did
enjoy seeing that and the cash in this
movie good cash miles teller Jamie Bella
Michael B Jordan kate mara Toby Kebbell
as doom kind of not at all though now
let's get to everything else really
nothing in this movie makes sense though
I mean human torch's dad really gets
this team together and it's like he
knows why he's getting them together how
it's supposed to be is in the movie it
makes sense that they're together and
then they end up forming the Fantastic
Four
or the fact this guy gets them all
together it defies logic to such a
degree where you have to think this guy
is like some sort of Marvel God he knows
that they're going to be the Fantastic
Four because there's no reason to have
Michael B Jordan work on this project
it's just not you're a really good
engineer I need you to help build this
thing know you have good engineers you
don't need this kid we're really issues
kind of a loose cannon and little-known
fact Reed Richards is a smartest man in
the Marvel Universe Victor Von Doom is
not smarter than him so when I see Reed
Richards write out a formula and Victor
Von dooms like no no no and he erases it
and writes at the forming they're like
oh I'm like okay so Victor's smarter
than Reed Richards so that's gone and
really the editing in this movie that
what is was they're editing the
transitions in between scenes and the
time-lapse thing it just doesn't work at
all and you hear stories about the
director came in shit-faced and drunk
off his ass I wasn't there I can't
qualify any of that I am saying when you
watch this movie earlier I can see this
movie being directed by someone who is
shit-faced every day sure and this movie
is long and really boring really nothing
happens in this movie just a bunch of
people trying to make something and then
they get powers but they don't really
and then it's just they have powers now
nothing's happening still that's where
I'm going to give credit to the other
Fantastic Four movie that came out in
2000 whatever at least in that one it
can pass it off as a fun comic book
adventure and the crew in there had some
form of synergy they did feel like
friends they felt like a Fantastic Four
these people look like actors who are
good actors who were trying to act their
way around a shitty script not having
any fun doing it there's no real fun not
in this movie that's one of the tonal
changes that were going for it's like
this new fresh take on Fantastic Four
which i'm down for but in the end when
that new fresh take ends up boring the
audience now I just go for the comic
book romp
instead everyone's brooding you know Ben
Graham he's like out there killing
people for the military's like the
things kill counts 43 Dan Grimm's like
oh I hate my life looks at the audience
like and you hate this too now
we're just gonna get to the last act of
the movie because this movie wasn't good
to begin with but then the last act of
this movie straight-up this movie
into the dirt dr. doom comes he's not
even dr. doom he's just doom he's not
even doom he's just dumb can we call him
dr. dumb will split the dollar so dr.
dumb pops onto the scene and he's just
it's soo man remember that set photo we
got we're look oh my god is he really
gonna look like that and people like me
were like calm down he might not look
like that in the movie just wait for it
to be on screen I'm here to tell you it
looks worse he just what the did he
look like
he looked like Dana's daughter and Star
Trek The Next Generation before she got
skinned it was like some weird psychic
biomechanical mannequin who would walk
by people and people just died because
he's that psychic and powerful seriously
he is nothing like that he's just
walking and people are just dying down
the hallways and it's just not what
Doctor Doom is dr. dumb in this movie is
every bit as much dr. doom as Baraka
pool was Deadpool in x-men origins
Wolverine he's that far off the mark
page is one of those things you look at
you're like I don't know where you guys
were gone with that I promise you they
did dr. doom better in that Fantastic
Four movie where I still profess that
was a shitty representation of Doctor
Doom and the entire life act of this
movie takes place in a wasteland there
are no stakes and by me there are stakes
involved earth is kind of imperil from
the happening in this place line
but you don't see any of it really you
don't feel that connection to the
gravity of the situation since I got a
band together to fight this psychic
biomechanical mannequin head data's
daughter without skin in a
Baroness boring wasteland just kind of
like the rest of this movie guys in the
end there were
things in fan for stick you could see
the glimmer you're like oh that's were
there girl guess not the execution is
not great the script is not great this
is one of those movies that's potential
but is there's a world of difference
between potential and realities boring a
in the last act is just laughable
the special effects some scenes look
fine other scenes I'm like that looks
like sci-fi channel there's a
scene where Reed Richards I guess can
like make his face look different and it
scatters his ability he has because he
can stretch his skin and he turns for
his face from one face into another face
it looked like something out of the
mummy I was terrible but it was what it
was awesome in that sense really like
you guys really didn't you just didn't
give a he just threw that the
screen you're like no one's gonna
remember that and they're right you're
not gonna remember fan for sticking
t-minus one hour
yep gone and forgotten but I will always
remember the shitty CGI face turning
into the other shitty CGI face that's
just there now okay so fam for stick
have you seen it what if you've seen it
by now we're a brave soul you're all
those people like I like people like you
because you're like no everyone says it
sucks but I need to see it for myself
god bless you Patriot but what did you
think of it whatever you like comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more